[Music]
zambia
is a religious conservative country
and it has some of the toughest
anti-homosexual laws in africa
many in this congregation are avid
supporters of their president's stand
against gay rights and appalled at the
american diplomatic intervention
and the zambian leader was unequivocal
about his stand on the issue when he
spoke to us
we are saying no to homosexuality why
should you
say we're going to be civilized if we
only allow it i'm saying we are very
primitive now because we are frowning
upon homosexuality
even animals don't do it why should we
be forced to do it because we want to be
seen to be smart to be seen to be
civilized and advanced and so
the row blew up after two men seen here
with their lawyer
were jailed for 15 years for taking part
in what's known in the country as a
crime against the order of nature
the legal term in zambia for gay sex
when the president doesn't want to hear
what i have to say
america's top diplomat in zambia in the
light suit
appears to have had a cordial
relationship with the zambian leader
up until now here he's being shown
around the statehouse gardens in lusaka
but the us diplomat said he was
personally horrified at the jailing
and in an uncharacteristically tough
statement for a diplomat
the ambassador lambasted the government
for corruption
said poachers got lighter sentences and
went on
decisions like this oppressive
sentencing do untold damage to zambia's
international reputation
by demonstrating that human rights in
zambia is not a universal guarantee
hi i'm dan foote the new united states
ambassador
to the republic of zambia it's all so
different from the american
ambassador's welcoming video on taking
up his post in zambia
more importantly we can't wait to engage
with the people of the country
the u.s is a big aid donor to zambia but
the zambian president said
no amount of money could make him change
his mind on homosexuality
retraction or apology would do but i
don't know to be honest with you
how far this matter will go because
already you're tying into ed
if that is how you're going to bring
your heads then i'm afraid the western
can
leave us alone in our poverty and we'll
continue scrounging and struggling and
see how we can
get going the president already
cancelled a meeting with the u.s
ambassador
and it's hard to see how their
relationship can be rebuilt
with such diverse views on homosexuals
they require help obviously for me
i think they're sick that's why i see it
but they need help
the fact that they went to jail probably
is one thing but help should be learned
to them
a pardon couldn't be considered but not
in the manner that the ambassador is
coming out
like like he's out in the collective
wisdom of the zambian people or the
sovereign
of this or you don't do that but the
jailing and the row
is likely to cement zambia's reputation
of being one of the most dangerous
places in africa to be gay
alex crawford sky news lusaka